transposes back into classical italians
which is of course also
pleasing magnus has tweeted
that he is withdrawing
from this tournament
hopes to be back doesn't give any more
specifics than that but he's not just
forfeiting today's game he's withdrawing
from the event wow and that is going to
have a change up in the standings i
believe that the grand chester
regulations do say that if a player has
not completed 50
of his games
then the games that he has played so far
will be annulled that means that none of
those games matter for the standings the
one against hans included they do count
for rating so han's still over 2700 and
magnus does lose those seven and a half
or whatever points that was
but uh hans basically moves down to one
and a half out of two instead of two and
a half out of three and all of the other
players that played against magnus as
well they have only played two games so
far instead of the full three uh
including young yeah jana is now tied
tied for the lead so to speak with only
two games played but jan is on plus one
having beaten uh alireza and the loss
against magnus in round one
uh now announced one uh yeah wesley is
still on plus one so we have as i
understand we have a three three-way tie
at the top right now with uh with hans
on plus one western plus
yeah
breaking developments all around yeah
we're going to be somewhat struggling to
catch up and we we apologize for this
likely haphazard nature of today's
stream but one of the things not really
up to us to a large degree yeah one of
the things as we start the show i always
ask you about our current standings and
we're gonna have to completely revive
those current standings because of a
breaking news a tweet from the world
chess champion magnus carlson yeah he
has withdrawn verbatim
alejandro what was the tweet exactly if
you please i've withdrawn from the
tournament i've always enjoyed playing
in the at st louis chess club and hope
to be back in the future
that is what the world champion has
tweeted so that definitely leads to
brief and to the point brief to the
point definitely no confusion about
whether it's just this game or the
entire tournament
he has withdrawn
and for us that means that there will be
no more magnus crossing games in this
tournament all the games that he has
played so far annulled
they do not count for our standings or
points but remember they do count for
raiding
yeah okay that's that's their whole
grand chess tour also in
uh with magnus now taking essentially
last place than the whole grand chester
i mean
if if we want to go in that direction
there's a there's a bunch of people in
this tournament for whom it is a good
financial news but right but it i assume
uh you know even for those fighting for
the gct tour uh
uh
victory uh this news cannot really come
as any kind of a positive
you you never want to see uh
these things happen and uh but again i
just want to reiterate that earlier
as we were starting the show david
sedgwick our international arbiter and
tour director that called for
enhanced security measures uh after all
anybody who's ever visited the saint
louis chess club and watched the players
as they enter see that they're very
carefully scanned and wanted but now uh
even extra measures were taking place
including some even delay of our
broadcast i believe that's also one that
is that is one of the security measures
just to be it just to be absolutely
absolutely ensuring uh a safe playing
venue for the players absolutely and uh
well uh
the withdrawal of magnus i'm still kind
of
processing people yeah it's it's going
to take a while but for now you know we
have the statement we we we know for
sure what's happening in regards to the
tournament everything else uh would be
speculation and i think speculating on
behalf of magnus is absolutely not not
our place here no
so we're
going to be
avoiding avoiding doing that
for the remainder of the broadcast and
i'm sure you understand
i'm sure our
audience certainly does i'm sure
you are all of us and let me go to a
game that i don't see very often lavon
erroneous left has been doing this
lanier now this is a